[Musique]
est-ce qu'il va pas un archos ce que je
vois mon la part ce vide et ça me fait
chier il temps de ma vie dans une pile
de cartons il rate un sac plastique et
les à caen puis 15 5 et vainqueur toi tu
sais à quelle date tu dois y être dans
une semaine
dans une semaine moi je t'en vas vivre à
l'ombre dans sept jours je suis pas au
courant parce que rien du tout fm c'est
un problème dans la vie il fasse rien du
tout et une actrice de folie c'est resté
une personne exceptionnelle
c'est le dernier jour dans l'appartement
comme c'est notre dernier soir je vais
un trou de deux hauts fourneaux voie
professionnelle boucher sans aucun
avenir
in fine et ensuite tu fermes les yeux tu
des temps l'étude mandat la bonne fée de
réaliser tous tes souhaits
[Musique]
que vous emmèneriez sur une île déserte
durera que deux personnes sur donc tu
peux choisir qu'une seule personne
on est obligé de dire la vérité rien que
la vérité
sincère
ses nuits avec toi ont été les meilleurs
et les pires moments de toute ma vie
les affaires qui roule devrait pas du
tout changé
même ce qui marche pour le mieux est
obligé d'évoluer souvent tu en penses
[Musique]